hey guys it's Jonah here
do you hate running on the treadmill
guess what I am NOT a big treadmill fan
as well I'm gonna show you seven
exercises which you can do on the
treadmill without running so each
workout will be for 45 seconds long with
15 seconds to rest in between and these
exercises will work your total body it's
going to work your legs your core and
also your upper body but the end of the
seven minutes your body will be on fire
and you will be burning calories
let's get onto the treadmill so get onto
the treadmill and set the speed to 1.5
kilometers or 2 kilometers the first
workout will be site shuffle so let's
start one side so just shuffle from the
left to the right as the treadmill is
moving and if you want to you can either
walk or you can get onto your toes
slightly and shuffle side to side and as
you progress what you can do is to
slowly increase the speed so we want to
work on one side and then switch over
and work on the other side good keep
shuffling and you should feel your outer
thighs and also a little bit on your
inner thighs
so this workout will really work on your
hips and then swap over and shuffle keep
going only ten seconds left you should
start to really feel your hips and also
your legs working and now just take a
short 15 seconds rest good just walk it
out the next exercise will be walking
lunges you can stick to the same speed
at 1.5 kilometers an hour and so let's
start on one side okay go left leg
forward and then step right leg forward
good so imagine that you're walking but
on the treadmill so the goal is to
really bring your knees down as close as
you can to the treadmill
and push up with your Hughes keep
looking forward and lunch so if you have
a really small space doing walking
lunges on a treadmill is a great idea
remember keep your body upright keep
your back straight and look forward and
lunge
feel your butt feel your hamstrings last
five seconds last one more and rest it
out good job now get off the treadmill
keep the treadmill running because the
next workout will be walking plank so I
wanted to place both hands on the
treadmill keep your core tight in a
plank position and just walk your left
arm and right hand forward and just hold
the plank position tighten your core and
keep your back flat so this workout will
really work on your core and target the
midsection avoid swinging your hips left
to right to make this workout slightly
easier what you can do is spread your
legs slightly wider if you're an
absolute beginner then you can always
start on your knees so remember keep
your back flat okay no peeking up or no
dipping or arching your lower back let's
go keep going don't stop now under ten
seconds left
see your sweat dripping and you should
really feel your entire body working and
rest it out good job
now get onto the treadmill and stop the
channel completely for the next four
exercises what we want to do is to work
on the treadmill without any movement so
the next workout it's going to be a
pull-up grab on to the handle okay and
just pull your body right up good this
workout will really work on your back
muscles especially your mid-back
so lower yourself down controlled pull
up
and squeeze your back muscles good lower
pull up and squeeze so remember to keep
your knees slightly bent and just focus
on working on your upper body avoid
using your legs good control pull up
squeeze good keep going squeeze the goal
is for your chest to almost touch the
bar squeeze last one more control and
pull it up good
15 seconds reps and the next workout
will be mountain climber so it's going
to be an incline mountain climber okay
the goal is to bring your knee close to
your elbow ready let's go
need to elbow control knee to elbow good
don't rush the workout I want it nice
and controlled and really squeeze your
abs again when you're in a plank
position keep your back flat and nice
and controlled movement incline mountain
combo will really work on your core even
more and you will also feel on your
upper body this is a harder version good
keep going knee to elbow knee to elbow
remember to breathe pace your breathing
[Music]
you have 10 seconds left squeeze those
ab muscles keep going last five more
seconds
last one more on both side and rest it
out the next workout is actually my
favourite workout but it is extremely
challenging so it's a plague knee tuck
with push up get your body ready we're
gonna start with a push-up so one pushup
and your goal is to pull the treadmill
right in tucking your knee towards your
abs another push up pull the treadmill
right in tuck it in bring your legs back
nice push up and pull it right in when
you pull the treadmill in that's when
you will really work on your lower abs
and also your upper abs good one more
push up now give me your best pull and
drag it in it may look easy but it is
not keep going good
as you progress what you can do is to
speed it up slightly pull it in knees to
your apps one last push up one last knee
tap pull it in squeeze and restaurant
well done
one final workout okay we're not
starting the treadmill so that final
workout is a treadmill push what I want
you to do is place both arms on the bar
and start pushing the treadmill and
start to move the treadmill okay this
workout will really work on your butt
muscles your quad and also your
hamstring and eventually once you get
the momentum you can start to run good
so tiptoe and start running and really
push against the handles good keep going
don't stop right now this is like
pushing and running up you keep going
push it squeeze your butt cheeks
keep pushing breathe pace your breathing
let's not stop right now you have ten
seconds left to the end of the workout
come and give me your best effort it's
only a seven-minute workout
keep going one last push and smile you
are done
right so that's your workout get this
workout done let me know how you feel at
the end of your workout let me know in
the comments below don't forget to share
this video challenge your friends to do
this seven-minute workout on the
treadmill and subscribe to my youtube
channel turn only your notification
button so that you will get notified
every time I upload a new video all the
best